un impressionnant campement a investi
les plaines de bonnel ce week end
1200 scouts d'europe venus de tous les
départements
trois jours de gadoue de rencontres et
d'activités en tous genres nous
retrouvons la troupe saint-quentinoise à
l'atelier secourisme certains sont
interrogés pendant que d'autres doivent
construire un brancard on fera ça aussi
on avait un blessé a transporté comprend
de bullway ont fait passer des montants
l'intérieur les ceinturons pour cette
rencontre annuelle est un peu synonyme
de compétition cette année les 40 unités
temps de se qualifier pour l'euro jam un
événement réunissant tous les scouts
d'europe
douze mille jeunes issus de 15 pays ils
se retrouveront en lorraine l'été
prochain rien qu'en france on compte
trente mille adhérents
autant dire que les places sont chères
c'est un grand événement qui n'arrive
que tous les dix ans donc il faut
essayer de sélectionner avec cette
épreuve
ont-ils une chance de se qualifier ça
veuille sont pas trop mal y'a pire il ya
pire prochaine étape l'atelier des
noeuds la troupe compte sur sa
complémentarité
moi personnellement c'est pas comme mon
grand fort mais j'ai des scouts il sera
séduit là dedans donc je pense que ça va
aller françois est le chef de patrouille
une hiérarchie spécifique à ce mouvement
catholique
c'est ce que dans le monde à un système
qui est bien à nous et qui nous
distingue vraiment des autres ce qu'on
fonctionne en patrouille l'air quand on
va confier un groupe de six personnes à
un jeune de 17 18 ans qui en a la charge
et chaque patrouille à sa tante et donc
ils sont tous arrivés là il ya cent
quarante et une patrouille pour les
yvelines ils sont tous arrivés ils ont
tous mis leurs tentes à l'atelier ne
pierre-marie se positionne comme le
spécialiste
les épreuves vont s'enchaîner tout au
long de la journée
ce soir place à la fête une grande
veillée se tiendra dans cet amphithéâtre
naturel